explain
to the audience why
an idea like the earth revolves around
the sun
is is it could be considered racist
because because everybody i i think
understands that the earth
the newtonian physics exists the earth
revolves around the sun i think that's
widely accepted in the west
yet in this idea of cynical theories
it it can be the the case like during
the you know medieval times where you
know the church said
you know everything revolved around the
earth and of course it took science and
and enlightenment period to actually
break that and a lot of people paid with
their lives
and were tortured for blasphemy but can
you explain that process because
i think people don't understand how
close we are to this
this idea where you're not allowed to
to dispute the you know what you
think or what you the narrative that
you've been given
okay so that there's a couple of things
um there and i want to get back to
whether
um corporations are really
um so sucked into this ideology i i tend
to think that they
are not as much as they seem but
before that yeah i will certainly um
explain how
this this idea works so so we do know
that the the earth orbits the sun we
know that this corresponds
with reality so in the
postmodern view of the world
there is that there are regimes of truth
um is how foucault called it there are
ways we legitimize knowledge and ways
that we set that we don't
so we have decided that science
is a what is a legitimate form of
knowledge therefore
we believe physicists when they tell us
that the earth orbits the sun however if
we lived in a different culture and they
legitimized knowledge differently
as you were saying with medieval times
when
and we're going with um holy myths or
you know some from other parts of the
world where the sun is a chariot being
driven across the sky
by a god that would be true
because of the way that culture
legitimated knowledge
what they say is um oppressive
is for us to say the scientific way of
um deciding what is true correspondence
with reality
is superior to other ways of deciding
which what is true which can be
tradition
lived experience perception of of
certain groups and there's this idea
that because the world is believed to be
set up to work
for straight white men um you assuming
you're straight
um can see the surface of it
and you everything just looks absolutely
normal to you
now anybody who diverges from that um
in a different way can see a bit more so
i as a woman
will notice sexist things which wouldn't
be a um
wouldn't be accessible to you i i don't
actually notice them because
i would see it because my own language
prevents me from seeing it yeah
the world works for you so everything
just seems to make common sense
but if you were a black trans woman
um for example then you would see the
world differently because you'd be able
to see
this the systems of power and privilege
that you can't currently see
so this is what is dry idea that we need
to hear less from straight white men
and we need to hear more from
marginalized groups because they have
another kind of knowledge which is
equally valid
and of course that that simply isn't
true so this is what we argue
about as well this is called standpoint
epistemology where we believe that
people's knowledge is tied to their
identity
and that's related to their position in
power
but if you look at the sheer range of
um black intellectual thought on racism
you know if you were to look at at
angela davis
next to thomas sal you you know this
there is
you'd find it difficult to believe that
um there's a racial standpoint
that gives people the same experience in
the same views
so so this is a nonsense but i
i agree that the social justice
narratives it does have too much
um influence we are seeing it in
corporations we're seeing people
withdrawing products with
um apologies we're seeing google
technicians being
fired for pointing out the truth that
men and women have different interests
on average but that doesn't tell us
anything about any individual
we're seeing this affect corporations
but i
don't um believe that this is because
these organizations have um
legitimately bought into these social
justice ideas
there is significant concern among
um businesses and and you're quite
powerful businesses and people are going
along
with these ideas because they believe
that quite often they don't understand
what they are